This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in the 1980s, Kyoki Skinner was a reporter with a newspaper called the Arizona Republic. He covered the drug trade and the border, and it's been a lot of time in different parts of Mexico. But he was getting tired of traveling and being a stranger in every place he went. He wanted to actually settle down in Mexico and to make a life. That's when I thought about, well, I would like to be part of a community in Mexico. But if I lived here and knew what was going on here, I could probably file some pretty good stories.
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。上世纪80年代，乔基·斯金纳（Kyoki Skinner）是《亚利桑那共和报》（Arizona Republic）的一名记者。他负责报道毒品贸易和边境问题，在墨西哥各地待过很长时间。但他厌倦了四处奔波，在每个地方都像个陌生人。他想在墨西哥真正定居下来，过上安稳的生活。那时我心想，嗯，我想成为墨西哥社区的一员。但如果我住在这里，了解这里发生的事情，我或许能写出一些非常好的报道。
So Kyoki moved to Agua Prieta, a town right on the border where he'd done some reporting before. Agua Prieta sits just across the line from Douglas, Arizona. The two cities are contiguous, one urban area that spans the border, divided by a towering rust-colored metal wall, a steep concrete ditch, a line of concertina wire, and a mesh fence. And Kyoki did what he'd set out to do. He settled down and made a life there. That's our own Delaney Hall.
于是乔基搬到了阿瓜普列塔（Agua Prieta），这是一个紧邻边境的小镇，他以前在那里做过一些报道。阿瓜普列塔就在亚利桑那州道格拉斯市（Douglas）的对面。这两座城市紧密相连，是一个横跨边境的城市区域，中间被一道高耸的铁锈色金属墙、一条陡峭的混凝土沟渠、一排蛇腹形铁丝网和一道网状栅栏隔开。乔基实现了他的目标。他在那里定居并开始了新的生活。这就是我们的德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。
He built a house, married a Mexican woman, continued mastering the slingy Spanish of Northern Mexico and ended up having five kids. Awa Prieta became his home. And the thing I liked about Awa Prieta, it wasn't tourism oriented at all. It was a very Mexican community. And I was very intrigued by the town for that reason.
他盖了一栋房子，娶了一位墨西哥妻子，继续精通墨西哥北部的俚语西班牙语，最终有了五个孩子。阿瓜普列塔成了他的家。我喜欢阿瓜普列塔的一点是，它完全不是以旅游为导向的。它是一个非常地道的墨西哥社区。正因如此，我对这个小镇非常着迷。
Kyoki ended up scaling back his full-time reporting job Mexican community. And I was very intrigued by the town for that reason. Kyoki ended up scaling back his full-time reporting job so he could open a smoothie shop and juice bar. What better way to get to know this city than to have a business here where people will come in and hang out and talk. He could listen and observe and probably pick up a few good ideas for the occasional freelance story that came his way. He named his smoothie shop, El Mito Te.
乔基最终缩减了他的全职记者工作。正因如此，我对这个小镇非常着迷。乔基最终缩减了他的全职记者工作，这样他就可以开一家冰沙店和果汁吧。还有什么比在这里拥有一家生意，让人们进来闲逛和聊天更好的方式来了解这座城市呢？他可以倾听和观察，并可能为偶尔遇到的自由撰稿故事收集一些好点子。他给他的冰沙店取名为“El Mito Te”。
Which in Spanish, it means like a gossip spot, or there's a ruckus going on, for example, the sirens going down the street. Everybody kind of runs out to see where the cop cars are going. And that's like, well, where's the Mito Te? What's going on? It's a hub hub type thing. Kyoki picked the name because on occasion,
在西班牙语中，这意指八卦场所，或者指发生了骚乱，比如警笛声在街上响起。每个人都会跑出来看警车要去哪里。这就好比，“Mito Te”在哪里？发生了什么事？这是一种喧闹的地方。乔基选这个名字是因为偶尔，
he'd been accused of being a mytho-theodle, meaning a nosy person, someone who prize. He wasn't working as a full-time journalist anymore, but that didn't mean he wasn't a reporter at heart. He loved collecting bits and pieces of information and asking questions, figuring out what was really going on. And so that's how I got the name for my business and it stuck. It stuck in fact to this day and how many years later I'll run into people like at a gas
他会被指责为“mytho-theodle”，意思是爱管闲事的人，喜欢打听的人。他不再做全职记者了，但这并不意味着他内心不再是一名记者。他喜欢收集各种信息，提出问题，弄清楚到底发生了什么。这就是我为我的生意取名的由来，而且这个名字一直沿用至今。多年后的今天，我还会遇到一些人，比如在加油站，他们看到我，会用西班牙语对我大喊：“嘿，金发八卦佬（Guero mitotero）！”他们不知道我的名字，但他们知道我开过那家店。不过，这很完美，因为这也是你第一次开始看到正在发生的巨大阴谋的证据的地方。是的，那里发生的事情并不难察觉。这些事情最终将乔基引向了他报道过的最大、最离奇的故事之一。你知道，今天的新闻，一位海关官员称之为詹姆斯·邦德电影里的情节。
station and they'll see me and they'll yell at me in Spanish. Hey, Guero mi totero which means hey you know blonde gossiper. They don't know my name but they know I had the mi toter. It's kind of perfect, though, because it's also where you first started to see evidence of this big conspiracy that was going on. Yeah, there was things going on there that wasn't hard to start picking up stuff. Stuff that would eventually lead Kyoki to one of the biggest and strangest stories he'd ever cover. You know, the news today, something that one customs agent called something out of James Bond.
这个故事涉及可卡因贸易。就在上周，又发现了600磅藏在卡车里的可卡因。“矮子”古兹曼（El Chapo Guzmán）。他一直是墨西哥头号通缉犯。大麻、可卡因、冰毒、海洛因和谋杀都是他生意的一部分。还有一项令人难以置信的工程和建筑壮举，将永远改变毒品贸易。1989年，乔基第一次开始注意到果汁店里有一些新顾客。他们是他以前没怎么见过的人。
The story involved the cocaine trade. Only last week, another 600 pounds of cocaine were found concealed in a truck. El Chapo Guzmán. He has been the most wanted man in Mexico. Marijuana, cocaine, meth, heroin and murder are all part of his business. And an incredible feat of engineering and architecture that would change the drug trade forever. It was 1989 when Kiyoki first started noticing some new customers in the juice shop. With guys he hadn't really seen before.
他们有一种特定的傲慢和态度，他说他们身边通常有保镖。这对于去果汁店来说并不典型。乔基形容他们是“锡那罗亚牛仔”类型。那么，当你提到这些锡那罗亚牛仔进来时，他们看起来是什么样子的？他们的行为举止如何？真正的高端牛仔靴、李维斯牛仔裤、皮背心、他们戴的白帽子，挂着锡那罗亚车牌的皮卡车。
They had a certain swagger and attitude and he says they often had bodyguards with them. Which is not typical for an outing to the juice shop. Kyoki described them as senolua cowboy types. So just when you say these senolua cowboys would come in, like what do they look like? What do they act like? Real high-end cowboy boots, the Levi's, the leather vest, the white hats that they wear, pick up trucks with senoloa plates.
他们都觉得自己凌驾于法律之上。他们把车停在我的店门口，根本不在乎。每个人都尽量避开他们，因为他们知道这些家伙来镇上是有目的的。在80年代末，锡那罗亚贩毒集团还不是今天这样庞大且占主导地位的犯罪组织，但它正朝着那个方向发展。该集团控制了穿过墨西哥锡那罗亚州和索诺拉州，然后越过边境进入亚利桑那州，再到凤凰城和洛杉矶等大型分销点的大部分毒品走私走廊。
They all feel like they were kind of above the law. They double park out in front of my place and they didn't give it damn. Everybody just kind of stayed away from them because they knew what was going on that these guys were in town for some something. Back in the late 80s, the Cinaloa Cartel wasn't quite the sprawling dominant criminal organization. It's become today, but it was headed in that direction. The Cartel controlled a lot of the drug trafficking quarter that ran through the Mexican states of the Sinaloa and Sonora, then across the border into Arizona and onto big distribution points like Phoenix and Los Angeles.
阿瓜普列塔正好位于那条走廊上。乔基怀疑这些在他的果汁店里用100美元钞票买冰沙的家伙是贩毒集团的成员。他开始观察他们，保持距离，但他也不排斥针对他们的喜好进行营销。我们向他们推销的一大特色是我们有一种叫“AR-15”的饮料。他们很喜欢这个。然后我们还有一种苜蓿汁。
Our Prieta fell right along that corridor. Kyogu suspected that these guys in his juice shop, buying their smoothies with $100 bills, were part of the cartel. He began observing them, caut from a distance, but he also wasn't above marketing to their sensibilities. And the big thing we hyped with them was we had drinks that we called AR-15. They love that one. And then we had an alfalfa drink.
我们吹嘘它对宿醉非常有效。所以他们会进来喝新鲜的苜蓿混合菠萝汁或其他什么东西。他们相信了我的广告策略，这就是他们会点的东西。乔基说，这是边境城镇的规则之一。即使涓滴经济学理论在其他地方站不住脚，在这里却行得通。当你处理边境城镇和毒品走私时，涓滴经济学是一个有效的概念，因为在墨西哥，这些家伙不会囤积钱财。
We hyped it as being real good for hangovers. So they would come in and drink fresh alfalfa mixed with pineapple or whatever. They bought into my advertising schemes, and that's what they would have. This Kiyoki says is one of the rules of border towns. Even if the theory of trickle-down economics doesn't really hold up in other places, it kind of works here. You're dealing with border towns and drug trafficking. Trichle down economics is a valid idea because in Mexico, these guys don't hoard the money.
钱会被花掉。花在豪宅和豪车上，更不用说给当地警察、政客和毒枭洗钱的企业行贿了。总的来说，乔基说，毒贩往往非常招摇。但有一个新人与那些穿着皮背心和高端靴子的锡那罗亚牛仔不同。
It gets spent. On stuff like big houses and fancy cars, not to mention bribes to local cops and politicians and businesses where the narcos launder their money. In general, Kiyoki says, drug traffickers tend to be pretty flashy. But there was one new guy that stood apart from the Sinaloa Cowboys with their leather vests
这个家伙穿得更像个商人。他的名字叫弗朗西斯科·拉斐尔·卡马雷纳-马西亚斯（Francisco Rafael Camarena-Macias）。有一天，他给了乔基一张名片，并告诉他一些他在镇上做的事情。他声称自己是瓜达拉哈拉的一名律师。他有一次来我的果汁吧时告诉我的故事是，他是一名承包商，打算在阿瓜普列塔盖房子。卡马雷纳还告诉乔基，他正在阿瓜普列塔的姐妹城市——亚利桑那州道格拉斯市寻求一些商业机会。
and high-end boots. This guy dressed more like a businessman. His name was Francisco Rafael Camarena-Maccias. And one day, he offered Kiyoki his business card and told him a little about what he was doing in town. Coming in, it claimed to be a lawyer at a Wadala Hada. The story that I got from him when he came into my jispar at one time was that he was a contractor and he was going to build houses in Awa Prieta. Kamadena also told Kyoki that he was pursuing some
当时我不知道底细。我觉得他挺正经的。乔基当时还不清楚卡马雷纳也从事毒品贸易。直到近一年后，整个道格拉斯市才意识到这一点。
business opportunities just across the border in Awa Prieta's sister city, Douglas, Arizona. And at that point, I didn't know what the score was. I thought he was pretty legit. It wasn't yet clear to Kiyoki that Kamadena was also in the drug trade. And it would take almost a year for that to become apparent to the entire city of Douglas as well.
到那时，卡马雷纳已经把这个小镇搅得天翻地覆。道格拉斯很小。1989年卡马雷纳刚出现时，这里大约有14,000人居住。它没有太多吸引人的地方。主要景点之一是加德森酒店（Gadson Hotel），它建于20世纪初，
And by then, Kamadena had already turned the little town upside down. Douglas is small. About 14,000 people lived here back in 1989 when Kamarena first showed up. It doesn't have a whole lot of attractions. One of the main ones is the Gadson Hotel, which was first built back in the early 1900s
当时该地区更多是吸引牧牛人、牧场主和矿业大亨的地方。它有一个宏伟的大理石大厅，还有那些华丽的蒂芙尼风格彩色玻璃窗。它们描绘了周围的索诺兰沙漠，有仙人掌、福桂树和灌木。今天，那片沙漠景观受到严密监视。一个配备摄像头和传感器的塔楼网络几乎24小时监视着南部边境和整个道格拉斯。
when the area was more of a magnet for cattlemen, ranchers, and mining tycoons. It has a grand marble lobby, and these gorgeous Tiffany-style stained glass windows. They depict the surrounding Sonoran desert, with its Suwara cactus, Ocatillo, and Creosot bushes. Today, that desert landscape is heavily surveilled. A network of towers equipped with cameras and sensors watch the southern border and all of Douglas
边境巡逻队的卡车贴着深色车窗在街上巡逻。这里有太多的历史，因为这一切都始于道格拉斯先生……你已经在录音了吗？是的，没关系吗？在城镇北侧，有一家叫“道格拉斯柴油”（Douglas Diesel）的店。这是一个巨大的砖砌仓库，墙皮剥落，里面装满了卡车零件。
pretty much 24 hours a day. Border patrol trucks with tinted windows cruise the streets. There's so much history here because this all started with Mr. Douglas, are you already taped recording me? Yeah, is that okay? On the north side of town, there's a shop called Douglas Diesel. It's a big brick warehouse with peeling stucco filled with truck parts.
店主是这个叫加里·詹姆斯（Gary James）的家伙。也许我们最好从头开始。好吧，首先，你叫什么名字，你是什么时候出生的？我叫加里·詹姆斯，我出生于1951年1月31日。加里在道格拉斯长大，几乎一生都住在这里。他帮助修理和维护那些穿过入境口岸的半挂车和卡车，这些车运载着在墨西哥制造的服装、电子产品、百叶窗和汽车零件。每月约有145,000辆私家车和超过2,000辆卡车越过边境。
And it's owned by this guy, Gary James. Maybe we better just start all over. Well, first of all, what's your name and when were you born? My name is Gary James, I was born 131-51. Gary grew up in Douglas and his live here almost all his life. He helps fix and service the semis and trucks that pass through the port of entry, hauling clothes, electronics, window blinds and car parts, manufactured in Mexico. About 145,000 personal vehicles and more than 2,000 trucks cross the border every month.
所以我的很多生意都来自墨西哥。事实上，我会说我大约80%的生意都来自边境以南。加里说，当你的客户是从事跨境运输业务的人时，其中一定比例的人会与走私有联系。当你有一个与美国接壤的外国，再加上我们美国存在的毒品问题，你就会一直有这种交易。在各种生意中，很多时候我知道来我店里的人可能不是100%合法的。
So a lot of my business is from Mexico. In fact, I would say probably 80% of my business is from south of the border. And Gary says that when your customers are people who work in the cross-border trucking business, a certain number of them will have ties to smuggling. When you have a foreign country that butts up to the United States and the drug problem that we have in America, you're going to have these kind of transactions all the time. In all kinds of businesses, and so many of times I know people coming in my shop may not be legit 100%.
但这仍然是生意。我是合法的，所以我卖给他们零件。但当加里第一次在当地一家酒吧见到拉斐尔·卡马雷纳时，他说他并没有怀疑卡马雷纳参与了任何走私。我记得他穿得很好，非常专业。
But it's still a business. I'm legit, so I sell them the parts. But when Gary first met Rafael, Kamarena out at a local bar, he says he didn't suspect that Kamarena was involved in any smuggling. I remember him being dressed very well, was very professional.
看起来从不激动或不安，也从没说过任何会让你质疑他身份的话。打扰一下。道格拉斯柴油。卡马雷纳外向且善于交际，他与道格拉斯一些最显赫的市民成为了朋友。这包括警察局长和拥有大量土地的当地治安官。卡马雷纳实际上买下了边境工业区附近的一块土地，
Never looked like he ever got excited or upset and never said anything that would make you question who he was. Excuse me. Doggie's diesel. Camadena was outgoing and social and he became friendly with some of Douglas's most prominent citizens. That included the chief of police and the local justice of the peace who owned a lot of land. Kamadena actually bought a plot of that land near an industrial part of the border,
他还买下了坐落在上面的当地企业。这家企业叫“道格拉斯预拌混凝土”（Douglas Reddimix），销售用于建筑项目的沙子、砾石和混凝土。卡马雷纳雇佣加里来帮助维修他的卡车。所以我至少每周都能见到卡马雷纳先生。至少对加里来说，卡马雷纳的生意看起来是合法的。所以道格拉斯预拌混凝土公司实际上在竞标联邦合同、城市合同、州合同，用于道路建设、桥梁建设所需的所有材料，所以它看起来是一项非常非常合法的生意。我的意思是，他雇佣了员工，所以我们都很高兴，因为当时亚利桑那州道格拉斯市没什么工业。
and he also bought the local business that sat on it. The business was called Douglas Reddimix, and it sold sand, gravel, and concrete for construction projects. Kamarena hired Gary to help service his trucks. And so I was seeing Mr. Kamarena, at least on a weekly basis. At least to Gary, Kamarena's business appeared to be above board. So the Davis Reddy Mix was actually bidding on federal contracts, city contracts, state contracts for all kinds of materials that are needed in road building, a bridge building, and so it looked like a very
所以它真的就在市中心。不远。离缉毒局（DEA）和海关人员驻扎的地方非常近。几乎就在他们的眼皮底下。乔基·斯金纳正开着他1973年的大众甲壳虫带我参观道格拉斯，车顶是帆布的，后保险杠上贴着一张贴纸，上面写着
very legit business. I mean he was employing people and so we were all happy because at that point in time there wasn't much industry in Douglas Arizona. Arizona. So it's really right downtown. Not far. Real close to where all the DEA and customs people were stationed. It's right under their nose pretty much. Kyoki Skinner is giving me the Douglas tour in his 1973 VW Bug, which has a flapping canvas roof and a bumper sticker on the back that says
“让美国再次成为墨西哥”，地图上显示了曾经属于我们南部邻国的美国领土。好了，就是这个仓库。现在，市政府一直用它来存放他们在道格拉斯周围运行的一些公交车和货车。在我们面前是一个被铁丝网围起来的米色仓库。卡马雷纳在80年代末为他的预拌混凝土生意建造了这个建筑。他把卡车、设备和材料存放在这里。
make America Mexico again, with a map showing the US territory that used to be part of our southern neighbor. Okay, this is this warehouse right here. Right now the city has been using it to store some of their buses and their bands that run around Douglas. In front of us is a beige warehouse surrounded by a chain link fence. Kamadena constructed this building for his ready-mixed business back in the late 80s. He stored his trucks and equipment and material here.
边境围栏大约在100英尺外。墨西哥就在那里。穿过围栏，就在界线那边，我们可以看到另一处曾经属于卡马雷纳的房产。那是阿瓜普列塔一个富人区的一栋牧场风格的住宅。卡马雷纳在一块空地上盖了这栋房子，据报道他花了9万美元现金买下了这块地。至少可以说，这比市场价格高出了一些。
The border fence is about 100 pieces away. Mexico is right there. And through the fence, just over the line, we can see another property that used to be Kamadenas. It's a ranch-style home in a wealthy neighborhood of Awa Prieto. Kamadena built the house on a vacant lot, which he reportedly bought for $90,000 cash. It was a little bit over and above market price to say the least.
这引起了一些人的怀疑。这家伙挥金如土。然后是房子后面那个巨大的洞。卡马雷纳告诉邻居那是打算建一个游泳池。但随着时间的推移，他们意识到它又开始被泥土填满了。所以有一天，邻居突然告诉我，你知道房子后面那个大洞吗？嗯，它全被填平了。没有游泳池出现，尽管房子里有很多建筑活动，
It raised some eyebrows. This guy was throwing around a lot of money. And then there was the enormous hole behind the home. Kamarena told his neighbors it was going to be a swimming pool. But as time went on they realized it was starting to fill up with dirt again. And so one day I was a sudden the neighbor told me, you know that big hole up was behind that, well it's all filled in. No pool had materialized, even though there was a lot of construction activity at the house with
卡车进进出出运送泥土。此时，因为道格拉斯和阿瓜普列塔都是相对较小的城镇，每个人都认识每个人。谣言开始流传。正如乔基所说的“Mito Tez”（八卦）。人们说卡马雷纳不仅在美国一侧建造了一个仓库，还在墨西哥一侧建造了一栋漂亮的住宅。他在两者之间建造了某种隧道。慢慢填满游泳池洞的泥土，显然是从边境下方挖出的一条通道里挖出来的。
trucks going in and out and hauling dirt. And at this point, because Douglas and Albert Prieta are both relatively small towns and everyone knows everyone else. Rumors were beginning to circulate. Mito Tez, as Kyoki would call them. People were saying that Kamarena wasn't just building a warehouse on the U.S. side and a nice residential home on the Mexico side. He was building some kind of tunnel between them. At dirt that slowly refilled the swimming pool hole, apparently it had been dug out of a passageway
道格拉斯以及后来凤凰城的美国海关官员最终收到了线人的多条举报。他们得知卡马雷纳正在利用这条通道将毒品从他在阿瓜普列塔的家中走私到他在道格拉斯的仓库。但在执法部门进入仓库搜查隧道之前，他们需要确定走私确实正在发生。
that ran under the border. US customs officials in Douglas and then in Phoenix eventually received a number of tips from informants. They learned that Kamadena was using the passageway to smuggle drugs from his home in Awaprieta across the border to his warehouse in Douglas. But before law enforcement could go into the warehouse to search for the tunnel, they needed to establish that the smuggling was actually happening.
于是他们监视了卡马雷纳的仓库。卡马雷纳的生意距离美国海关总部仅一个街区。这后来被记录在《未解之谜》（Unsolved Mysteries）的一集中。非常戏剧性。1990年初，我们对道格拉斯预拌混凝土公司进行了24小时监视。我想我们有发现了。特工们监视了卡马雷纳的生意两个多月。是的，卡马雷纳，没错。
So they staked out Kamadena's warehouse. Kamarena's business was located one block away from the US customs headquarters. This was later chronicled in an episode of Unsolved Mysteries. It was very dramatic. Early 1990, we initiated a 24-hour surveillance of the Douglas Reddy Mix Company. I think we've got something. Agent staked out Kamarina's business for over two months. Yes, Kamarain, alright.
执法部门最终跟踪了一辆他们看到离开卡马雷纳仓库的平板卡车。他们一直跟踪到凤凰城外的一处房产，并在那里进行了突袭。特工们突袭了一个卡马雷纳的卡车曾出现过的农场。你们带着搜查令来的。特工们查获了超过一吨近乎纯净的可卡因。就在那儿。
Law enforcement eventually followed a flatbed truck that they'd seen leaving Comerainers warehouse. And they trailed it to a property outside of Phoenix, where they conducted a raid. Lawyers has raided a farm where Comerainers truck had been seen. You guys come to the search warrant. Agent seized over a ton of nearly pure cocaine. There it is.
街头价值超过1亿美元。可卡因被装在卡车车厢下的一个隐藏隔间里。突袭证实了毒品来自卡马雷纳的仓库。1990年5月，执法部门突袭了卡马雷纳在道格拉斯的仓库和他位于阿瓜普列塔的家。他们听说有一条隧道，但他们并不真正知道它会是什么样子。第一反应是，好吧，一条隧道。
Street value over $100 million. The cocaine had been transported inside a hidden compartment beneath the truck's bed. The raid confirmed that the drugs had come from Camarena's warehouse. In May of 1990, law enforcement rated Camarenaorant as warehouse and Douglas and his home in Aguapriata. They'd heard there was a tunnel, but they didn't really know exactly what it would be like. The first reaction was like, okay, a tunnel.
听起来像是一个小洞，像个地鼠洞，这些家伙是爬着过去的吗？这是特里·柯克帕特里克（Terry Kirkpatrick）。他当时在美国海关工作，他就在突袭当晚在现场。特工们首先进入了美国一侧的仓库。在楼层中间，有一个大约两英尺乘两英尺的格栅。那个格栅恰好就是通往隧道下方的竖井。
Does it sound like some little bitty hole, like a go-for-hole, if these guys are crawling through? This is Terry Kirkpatrick. He worked with the U.S. Custom Service at the time, and he was there the night of the raids. First agents entered the warehouse on the U.S. side. And in the middle of the floor, it was probably about a two-foot by two-foot grate. Well that grate just happened to be the shaft leading down into the tunnel.
一旦他们在道格拉斯仓库发现了隧道入口，一些特工就前往阿瓜普列塔，在那里他们与墨西哥联邦司法警察会合。他们发现卡马雷纳和他的家人已经逃跑了。他的房子是空的。没有人，但他们找不到进入隧道的入口，他们搞不清楚。我们也不确定怎么进去。特工们走进了一个看起来像是有台球桌的娱乐室。当他们掀开地毯时，他们可以看到地板有些不同寻常。
Once they'd found the tunnel entrance in the Douglas warehouse, some of the agents headed over to Aua Prieta, where they were joined by the Mexican Federal Judicial Police. They discovered that Kamadena and his family had already fled. His house was empty. No one was there, but there was no access to the tunnel they couldn't figure it out. We weren't sure how to get into it either. The agents went into what looked like a recreation room with a pool table in it. And when they pulled away the carpet, they could see there was something unusual about the floor.
看起来台球桌下面有一块独立的混凝土板，一种巨大的活板门。特工们开始寻找可能打开它的按钮或杠杆。有人还拿出了手提钻。我恰好是那个拿着手提钻，开始在台球桌上方地板上钻孔的人。当我站在那里钻孔时，它突然动了，开始上升，然后停住了。所以大家都愣住了，我们说，好吧，谁碰了什么？
It looked as if there was a separate concrete slab underneath the pool table, a kind of enormous trap door. The agent started looking around for some kind of button or lever that might open it. And someone also pulled out a jackhammer. And I just happened to be the one that took the jackhammer and started jackhammering the floor on top of where the pool table was. As I'm standing there jackhammering it all was sudden it moved and started to go up, and then it stopped. And so everybody kind of froze and we said, okay, who touched what?
结果，外面的一名警察正试图从外面的水龙头接水喝。当他拧开那个水龙头时，那实际上是一个控制杆，允许台球桌升起。阀门触发了台球桌在巨大的液压升降机上上升到天花板。就像机械修理厂里的东西一样，露出了下面的一组楼梯，通向隧道。这就是他们在边境道格拉斯一侧发现入口的那条隧道。隧道位于地下约30英尺处。一旦特工们到达底部，就有一条通道。
Well, it just so happened that one of the policemen outside was trying to get a drink of water out of an outside water spiket. And when he turned that spiket, that's what was a control lever that allowed the pull table to go up. The valve triggered the pull table to rise up to the ceiling on huge hydraulic lifts. Like something in a mechanics garage, revealing a set of stairs underneath which descended into the tunnel. The same one they'd found in entrance to on the Douglas side of the border. The tunnel was located about 30 feet underground. Once agents had the bottom, there was a passageway.
大约270英尺长，4英尺宽，5英尺高，刚好够一个人稍微弯着腰走过去，推着一辆装满可卡因包裹的轮式推车。隧道有混凝土墙和弯曲的混凝土屋顶。有通风系统和简易照明。所以这不仅仅是一个地鼠洞。这显然是一个复杂的工程项目。整个隧道的复杂程度是前所未见的，闻所未闻的，我想美国政府中没有人，
About 270 feet long, four feet wide, if five feet high, just tall enough that a person could walk through slightly stooped, pushing a wheeled cart full of bundles of cocaine. The tunnel had concrete walls and a curved concrete roof. There was a ventilation system and rudimentary lighting. So this wasn't just a go-for-whole. This was clearly a sophisticated engineering project. Just the complexity to this whole tunnel was something that had been unseen before unheard of and no one I think in the United States government,
特别是在执法部门，意识到这些东西的存在。好吧，在墨西哥-亚利桑那边境巡逻的联邦特工今天说，他们发现了一条主要的毒品走私路线，这是他们以前从未关注过的地方。昨晚发现的价值约200万美元的建筑，混凝土钢筋，电力，5英尺高，4英尺宽，有一个足球场那么长。海关官员说，隧道的发现几乎是道格拉斯发生过的最大的事情。
especially in law enforcement, realized any of the things ever existed. Well, federal agents on patrol along the Mexico Arizona border said today that they discovered a major drug smuggling route where they had never looked before. An estimated $2 million worth of construction discovered last night, concrete steel reinforcing bars, electrica zona five feet high four feet wide the length of a football field customs agents say the discovery of the tunnel was pretty much the biggest thing
每个人都在关注，我的意思是每个人。我们有国会议员来到亚利桑那州道格拉斯，你知道，《美国头号通缉犯》和《未解之谜》都来了，在隧道被发现后的至少第一年里，我们这里有很多活动。那是持续不断的。那是持续不断的。我一直听到黑鹰直升机降落的声音。好吧，今天是谁来了？
that had happened in Douglas everybody was paying attention I mean everybody and we had congress people come out to Douglas Arizona and you know America's most wanted and unsolved mysteries and we just had a lot of activity here for at least the first year after the tunnel was discovered. It was constant. It was just constant. I'd hear the helicopters, the black hawks landing all the time. Well who is it today?
你知道，约翰·麦凯恩（John McCain）。那个地方就像中央车站一样。乔基在果汁店的轮班间隙开始报道。加里继续维修半挂车，但也受雇于联邦政府帮助维护和保护仓库现场，以便执法部门可以进出。海关部门进行了大规模调查，人们开始印制T恤和保险杠贴纸，上面写着“我看到了隧道”，并把它们卖给所有来访的政客和记者。
You know John McCain. It was like Grand Central Station in that place. Kiyoki started reporting in between shifts at the JuShop. Gary kept servicing semis, but was also hired by the federal government to help maintain and secure the warehouse site so law enforcement could come and go. The Custom Service undertook a massive investigation, and people started printing t-shirts and bumper stickers, which said, I saw the tunnel and selling them to all the visiting politicians and journalists.
每个人，政府官员、记者、执法人员、道格拉斯的普通市民，他们都在问同样的问题。首先，是谁提供了建造这条隧道的资金？据估计，建造它花费了100万到200万美元，所以这个项目显然有更大规模行动的资金支持。另一个问题是，谁有专业知识？一个懂工程技术的人参与其中。一个知道如何建造隧道，不被发现，延伸了一个足球场那么长，
And everyone, government officials, reporters, law enforcement, ordinary citizens of Douglas, they were all asking the same questions. First, who provided the money to build this tunnel? It was estimated to have cost one to two million dollars to create, so the project clearly had the financing of a much bigger operation. And the other question was, who had the expertise? Someone with engineering know-how had been involved. Someone who knew how to build a tunnel, undetected, that stretched the length
并穿过巨大的边境围栏和隔开墨西哥与美国的混凝土排水沟。所以大家立刻都在议论，谁投资了这个？谁是这次行动的头目？当然，他的名字开始出现了。名字是华金·“矮子”·古兹曼（Joaquin El Chapo Guzman）。最终，随着调查的进展，另一个人也开始出现了。一位建筑师。建筑师的到来。稍后继续。现在，在纽约，一场大规模的审判正在进行中。华金·古兹曼·洛埃拉（Joaquin Guzman-Loera），也就是众所周知的“矮子”，是历史上最强大的毒枭之一。这次审判对美国政府来说是一件大事，他们几十年来一直试图抓捕“矮子”并让他承担责任，但都失败了。
of a football field, and ran under the massive border fence and concrete drainage ditch that separated Mexico from the US. So right away everybody was talking like, who invested in this? Who is the kingpin of this operation? And of course his name started coming up. The name was Joaquin El Chapo Guzman. And eventually, as the investigation progressed, someone
“矮子”在再次被捕并引渡到美国之前，曾两次从墨西哥监狱逃脱。现在，当他被从关押他的曼哈顿联邦监狱转移到审判地布鲁克林的法院时，他被锁在一个听起来基本上像棺材的东西里。据说这位毒枭被锁在一个安全舱内，该舱固定在装甲车的地板上，里面由一队配备自动武器的警官保护，
else started coming up too. An architect. The arrival of the architect. After this. Right now, in New York, a massive trial is underway. Joaquin Guzman-Loeira, better known as El Chapo, is one of the most powerful drug kingpins ever to face prosecution. This trial is a huge deal for the U.S. government, which tried unsuccessfully for decades to capture El Chapo and hold him accountable.
并由能够击退攻击的突击队式车队护送。为了防止对车队的袭击并冒着“矮子”再次逃脱的风险，当局在将他送往法庭时关闭了布鲁克林大桥。在审判初期，早在11月，当检察官开始阐述锡那罗亚贩毒集团行动的范围和规模时，陪审员们观看了1990年发现的道格拉斯隧道的视频导览。向公众发布的录像没有声音，
El Chapo escaped from Mexican prisons not once but twice before finally being arrested again and externated to the U.S. Now when he's being transported from the federal prison in Manhattan where he's being held to the courthouse in Brooklyn where his trial is happening, he's locked in what basically sounds like a coffin. The drug lord is said to be locked inside a security capsule, which is fixed to the floor of an armored vehicle, protected inside by a team of officers with automatic weapons,
但它显示特工们弯着腰走过混凝土通道，并显示了台球桌下方的混凝土板在液压升降机上从地板上升起。在“矮子”的领导下，锡那罗亚贩毒集团以其创造性的走私方法而闻名，尤其是他们的隧道。道格拉斯的那条隧道成为了后来许多隧道的原型。负责监督其建造的人是一个名叫费利佩·德·赫苏斯·科罗纳·贝尔巴拉（Felipe de Jesus Corona-Verbara）的人。隧道确实始于一个名叫费利佩·德·赫苏斯·科罗纳·贝尔巴拉的家伙，他是一位
and escorted in a commando-style convoy capable of repelling attack. In an effort to prevent an assault on the caravan and risk another chopper escape, authorities are closing the Brooklyn bridge while delivering him to court. Early on in the trial, back in November, as prosecutors began to lay out the scope and scale of the Cinaloa Cartel's operation, jurors were given a video tour of the Douglas Tommel, one discovered back in 1990. The footage released to the public doesn't have sound,
建筑师。他于1980年毕业于瓜达拉哈拉大学，获得建筑学学位。除了这个事实，关于他的早年生活知之甚少。这是蒙特雷（Monterey）。他是《华盛顿邮报》的南美通讯员，曾为《纽约客》撰写过关于跨境隧道的文章。他说，虽然拉斐尔·卡马雷纳可能是隧道项目的门面，但在幕后，是科罗纳·贝尔巴拉提供了技术专长。科罗纳·贝尔巴拉并没有……我们稍后会详细讨论这一点，但他在2006年自己的联邦审判中被判犯有共谋罪和毒品走私罪。我们对他了解的很多信息都基于那次审判的证词。这些故事是从帮助他完成某些建筑项目的合同工那里收集的，也来自前贩毒集团成员的证词。像米格尔·安赫尔·马丁内斯（Miguel Angel Martinez）这样的贩毒集团成员，他曾担任飞行员，后来成为“矮子”的副手，之后转为污点证人并进入证人保护计划。在80年代和90年代，马丁内斯帮助管理“矮子”的生意。有一段时间，他协调了从哥伦比亚到阿瓜普列塔的可卡因运输。
but it shows agents walking stooped through the concrete passageway, and it shows the concrete slab below the pool table, floating up from the floor on its hydraulic lifts. Under the leadership of El Chompo, the Cinaloa Cartel became known for their creative smuggling methods, especially their tunnels. The one in Douglas became a kind of prototype for many tunnels afterwards. And the person who oversaw its construction was a man named Felipe de Jesus, Corona Verbara. The tunnels really started with a guy named Felipe de Jesus, Corona Verbara, who was an
当他出庭指控科罗纳·贝尔巴拉时，他形容他是，他所知道的锡那罗亚贩毒集团中唯一一个用“你”（tu）这个代词称呼“矮子”，而不是更正式和尊重的“您”（usted）的人。所以他被认为是一个与古兹曼非常亲近且非常熟悉的人。但我不知道是否有人真正知道他们是如何相识的故事。我们可能不知道那个故事，但我们确实知道，总的来说，一些建筑师是如何为毒贩工作的。基本上就像在任何商业社区一样。
architect. He graduated from the University of Guadalajara in 1980 with an architectural degree. And there's not much known about his early life beyond that fact. This is Monterey. He was the South America correspondent for the Washington Post, and he's written about transporter tunnels for the New Yorker. And he says that while Rafael Comet and I may have been the frontman for the tunneling project, behind the scenes it was Kuronavid Beta, who provided technical expertise. Kuronavid Beta did not eyes this. We'll get into that a bit more later, but he was convicted
这是乔安·格里洛（Yoan Grillo），一位常驻墨西哥城的英国记者。他报道毒品贸易和毒品战争近20年了。就像如果你要盖房子，你说你需要一位建筑师，你可能会四处打听，你知道，谁认识好的建筑师，这是一个市场。如果有人走过来提供非常好的报酬，超过你通常能赚到的钱，这可能是一个难以拒绝的提议。而且因为贩毒集团是如此广泛和复杂的行动，他们需要多种类型的子专家。他们最终雇佣的不仅是建筑师和工程师，还有会计师、律师、IT专家，甚至还有为某些毒枭的夸张事迹写民谣的音乐家。
of conspiracy and drug smuggling in his own federal trial in 2006. And a lot of what we know about him is based on testimony from that trial. Stories that have been collected from contract workers who helped him with certain construction projects and also from testimony from former cartel members. Cartel members like Miguel on Hill Martinez, who worked as a pilot and later as a lieutenant-fraile chapo before turning state's witness and entering witness protection. Back in the 1980s and 90s, Martinez helped to manage El Chapo's business. For a time he coordinated cocaine deliveries from Colombia to Awa Prieta.
这些人中的许多人被雇佣从事一次性工作，就像承包商一样。所以你有职业杀手，他们被雇佣并领取工资或按次付费。你有那些背着装满毒品的背包穿过沙漠的人，通常按他们带过去的背包数量付费，还有那些被付钱建造隧道的人，所以他们按工作付费。据前贩毒集团成员米格尔·安赫尔·马丁内斯称，建筑师科罗纳·贝尔巴拉在开始道格拉斯隧道之前，为“矮子”做过许多建筑项目。
And when he testified against coronavirus, he described him as being, The only guy that he ever knew within the Centelo cartel who addressed Choppa with the pronoun two instead of the more formal and deferential instead. So he was considered a guy who just was very close friends and very familiar with Gussmann. But I'm not sure if anybody really has the story of how they met. We may not know that story, but we do know, generally speaking, how some architects come to work for drug traffickers. Basically it's like in any business community.
他最初的项目只是墨西哥境内与隧道无关的建筑工作。他为古兹曼建造了几栋住宅，并帮助设计了一个带有动物园的农场，古兹曼在那里饲养了一些珍奇宠物。他还设计了一家杂货店，锡那罗亚贩毒集团在顶层有一些办公室。所有这些项目，无论是农场、住宅
This is Yoan Grillo, a British journalist based in Mexico City. He's covered the drug trade and the drug war for almost 20 years. Like if you're going to build a house and you say you need an architect, you might ask around, you know, who knows a good architect, and it's a marketplace. And if you have somebody coming up and offering very good money, above what you might normally make, it can be an offer that's hard to refuse. And because cartels are such extensive and elaborate operations, they need many kinds of sub-specialists. They end up hiring not just architects and engineers, but also accountants, lawyers, IT experts, and even musicians who write ballads about the exaggerated exploits of certain arcos.
还是杂货店，都有某种天赋。所有这些项目的共同点是，它们都具有通过这些液压系统进入的隐藏空间。科罗纳·贝尔巴拉设计的系统几乎有一种俏皮感。他在开发进入这些秘密通道的方法方面非常有创造力，走进房子的人永远不会猜到。1988年，科罗纳·贝尔巴拉从墨西哥瓜达拉哈拉搬到了道格拉斯-阿瓜普列塔地区，带着
Many of these people are employed for one-off jobs, like contractors. So you have professional killers who are hired and paid a wage or paid for a hit. You have people who are walk over the desert with the backpack flow drugs and are paid normally per backpack they take over and you have people who are paid to build tunnels and so they they paid for the job. According to Miguel Angel Martinez, the former cartel member, the architect, Coronev Edberta, worked on a number of building projects for El Chapo
他的妻子和三个孩子。在联邦审判中，他的辩护团队坚持认为这是为了从事合法项目。他们辩称，像该地区的许多人一样，科罗纳·贝尔巴拉无意中卷入了与有贩毒集团背景的人做生意，但他并没有真正设计或建造隧道。他们请来了一位专家作证说，隧道看起来更像是结构工程师而不是建筑师的作品。
before embarking on the Douglas tunnel. And his first projects were just kind of construction jobs within Mexico that weren't related to tunnels. He had built a couple of residential homes for Guzman and he had helped design a farm with a zoo where Choppo kept some of his exotic pets. And he designed a grocery store where the Cinaloa cartel had some offices up in the top floor of it. And all of these projects, whether a farm or a home
审判记录变得非常详细和专业，提到了控制缝、养护化合物和入口结构等内容。辩方称该地区的腐败猖獗，科罗纳·贝尔巴拉的不幸在于在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。而且有一些证据表明，还有其他专家参与了隧道建设。一位高级海关官员告诉我，向他举报隧道的线人之一是一名墨西哥工程师。该工程师声称他被锡那罗亚贩毒集团雇佣来研究可能的隧道位置，
or a grocery store, had a certain flare. The one thing that all of those projects had in common was that they featured hiding places that were all accessed by these hydraulic systems. There's a playfulness almost to the sort of systems that coronavirus was designed. He was very creative in developing ways to access these secret passageways that somebody who walked into a house would never really guess. In 1988, coronavirus moved from Guadalajara, Mexico to the Douglas, Awa Prieta area with
并创建隧道设计，然后交给科罗纳·贝尔巴拉。这个细节很难核实，但它来自可靠来源。即使在被定罪并服刑十多年后，科罗纳·贝尔巴拉仍然否认参与了隧道。他的律师告诉我们，他也否认参与了任何之前的“矮子”古兹曼项目。我们要求采访科罗纳·贝尔巴拉，但通过一位朋友，他告诉我们他目前不愿接受采访。尽管拒不认罪，但科罗纳·贝尔巴拉还是被发现在关键的隧道地点出现过，包括美国一侧的仓库和阿瓜普列塔一侧的住宅。
his wife and three kids. And in the federal trial, his defense team maintained that it was to work on legitimate projects. They argued that, like a lot of people in the area, coronavirus inadvertently got caught up doing business with people who had cartel connections, but that he didn't actually design or build the tunnel. They brought in an expert to testify that the tunnel looked more like the work of a structural engineer and not an architect.
许多当地承包商和工人都报告说在那些建筑工地与他有过互动。他们形容他是一个他们经常交谈的人，总是出现在那里，有趣的是，很多人实际上用溢美之词来形容他。例如，有一位承包商描述看到科罗纳·贝尔巴拉为仓库准备的计划。他在作证时停顿了一下，说那是美丽的计划。
The trial transcripts get very detailed and jargony, with references to things like control joints and curing compounds and inlet structures. The defense says corruption in the area was rampant, and it was coronavirus misfortune to be in the wrong place at the wrong time. And there is some evidence that there were other specialists involved with the tunnel. A senior customs agent told me that one of the informants who tipped him off to the tunnel was a Mexican engineer. The engineer claimed he'd been hired by the Cinaloa cartel to research possible tunnel locations
所以他们有点尊重这个家伙作为建筑师的身份。他身上有一种气质，人们把他看作是一个知道自己在做什么的人。但也有一些迹象表明这不是一个普通的建筑项目。例如，仓库地板上的排水沟。一名工人对它们的大小提出了质疑，以及它们似乎没有通向清晰的排水系统的事实。这是因为它们实际上要通向通道，
and to create tunnel designs Which were then handed off to coronavirus. That detail is hard to fact check, but it comes from a credible source Even after being convicted and serving more than a decade in federal prison coronavirus still denies being involved with the tunnel His attorney told us that he also denies involvement in any previous Chapo Guzman projects. We asked coronavirus barra for an interview, but through a friend he told us that he's not willing to speak at this time. Despite pleading not guilty, coronavirus was seen at key tunnel locations, including both the warehouse on the US side and the residential
连接到隧道。其中一名工人说，这些排水沟，它们不……它们有些不对劲。水流向哪里？他当时在质疑设计，而科罗纳·贝尔巴拉基本上说，少管闲事。这里我说了算。
home on the Agua Prieta side. A number of local contractors and workers reported interacting with him at those construction sites. They described him as somebody that they would talk to all the time, who was always around, and it's funny, a lot of people actually describe him in glowing terms. For instance, there was a contractor who described seeing the plans that coronavirus had for the warehouse. And he kind of paused in his testimony and said they were beautiful plans.
锡那罗亚贩毒集团之所以选择阿瓜普列塔-道格拉斯边境作为隧道地点，有几个原因。首先，贩毒集团已经在那里运作了。他们建立了网络并建立了行动，而且他们已经在地面上，主要是通过带有隐藏隔间的货车和卡车，将毒品运过边境。他们能够通过这种方式每月运送约三吨毒品过境，但古兹曼想要更高的效率。
So they kind of respected this guy as an architect. He kind of had this air about him that people looked at him as somebody who knew what he was doing. But there were also a few signs that this wasn't an ordinary construction project. For instance, the drains in the floor of the warehouse. One worker raised questions about their size, and the fact that they didn't appear to lead to a clear drainage system. This was because they were actually going to lead into the passageway,
为了理解为什么“矮子”古兹曼想要更高的效率，我们需要去迈阿密做一次小小的侧面旅行。早在80年代初，大部分可卡因进入美国不是来自墨西哥，而是来自哥伦比亚。哥伦比亚贩毒集团更喜欢通过船只和小飞机，经由迈阿密等南佛罗里达城市将毒品走私到美国。迈阿密是供应美国三分之二毒品消费的源头，毒品贸易助长了犯罪激增。因此，里根政府开始了一些行动。
the connected to the tunnel. And one of the workers said, these drains, they don't, there's something not right with them. Where does the water go? He was kind of questioning the design and coronavirus. Basically, said, mind your own business. I'm in charge here.
连接到隧道。其中一名工人说，这些排水管不太对劲。水流向哪里？他当时在质疑设计，而科罗纳维斯基本上说，少管闲事。这里我说了算。
The Cinaloa cartel had hand picked the Aua Prieta Douglas border as a tunnel site for a few reasons. For one thing, the cartel was already operating there. They had established networks and have established operation, and they'd already been moving drugs across the border, above ground, mostly in fans and trucks, with hidden compartments. And they were able to move about three tons per month across the border that way, but Guzman wanted more efficiency.
锡那罗亚贩毒集团之所以精心挑选阿瓜普列塔与道格拉斯之间的边境作为隧道选址，有几个原因。首先，该集团已经在那里开展活动。他们建立了网络和运营基地，并且已经通过地面运输将毒品运过边境，主要使用带有隐藏隔层的货车和卡车。他们通过这种方式每月能运送约三吨毒品，但古兹曼想要更高的效率。
And understand why El Chabo Guzman wanted more efficiency, we need to take a little side trip to Miami. Back in the early 1980s, most cocaine was coming into the US not from Mexico, but from Colombia. And the Colombian cartels preferred smuggling drugs into the country on boats and small plains through cities in South Florida, like Miami. Miami is the source that supplies two thirds of America's drug habit, and the drug trade was helping to fuel a surge in crime. And so the Reagan administration started something
要理解为什么“矮子”古兹曼想要更高的效率，我们需要去迈阿密做个小小的侧记。回到20世纪80年代初，大部分可卡因进入美国不是来自墨西哥，而是来自哥伦比亚。哥伦比亚贩毒集团更喜欢通过船只和小型飞机，经由迈阿密等南佛罗里达城市将毒品走私入境。迈阿密是供应美国三分之二毒品需求的主要来源，而毒品贸易助长了犯罪率的激增。因此，里根政府启动了一项计划
called the South Florida Task force to fight it. It looks like a war. Customs agents on assignment ready for combat. High-speed Cobra helicopters from the Army with marijuana leaves painted on the side, each leaf a successful drug bust. Reagan's goals for the task force were very ambitious. Our goal is to break the power of the mob in America and nothing short of it. We mean to end their profits, imprison their members and cripple their organizations. But the reality is the harder we make it for smugglers to get goods across the border, the more money ends up getting pumped into the system.
成立了南佛罗里达特别工作组来打击它。这看起来像是一场战争。海关特工随时准备战斗。陆军的高速眼镜蛇直升机侧面画着大麻叶，每一片叶子都代表一次成功的毒品查获。里根对特别工作组的目标非常宏大。我们的目标是打破美国黑帮的势力，除此之外别无他求。我们打算终结他们的利润，监禁他们的成员，并摧毁他们的组织。但现实是，我们越是让走私者难以将货物运过边境，就会有越多的钱注入这个系统。
Militarizing our border over many decades has an ended illegal trafficking. It's just helped professionalize it. The more you crack down on it, the harder it gets. Yo and Grillo again. The harder it gets, the price goes up. The more the price goes up, the more money is made. The more money is made, the more criminals want to do it. so the criminals that adapt to it and are richer are more powerful organizations. And the Mexican cartels were about to get a lot richer and more powerful. Thanks in part to Reagan's strategy of increased enforcement in South Florida. Because when the Colombian cartels saw that they were losing their product in drug busts
几十年来，边境军事化并没有结束非法贩运。它只是使其专业化了。你打击得越严，它就越困难。再次引用Yo和Grillo的话。越困难，价格就越高。价格越高，赚的钱就越多。赚的钱越多，罪犯就越想做。所以那些适应了这种情况并变得更富有的罪犯，就成了更强大的组织。而墨西哥贩毒集团即将变得更加富有和强大。这在一定程度上要归功于里根在南佛罗里达加强执法的策略。因为当哥伦比亚贩毒集团看到他们的产品在毒品查获中损失时，
in Miami, they just looked to a different border and new criminal collaborators. So they turned to Mexico. There's a agreement made where they would pay the Mexicans to take the cocaine from them. Mexico already had a big trafficking route into the United States. So all the Colombas I have to do is bring it up to Mexico. Mexicans could take it and then take the United States and deliver it to them at a price, per kilo, or per ton, or they're negotiating. So suddenly, a lot of the cocaine that had been traveling around or over Mexico was now traveling through it, and then across the southern border into the US, which meant a lot of new money pouring into the Mexican cartels.
在迈阿密，他们只是寻找不同的边境和新的犯罪合作者。所以他们转向了墨西哥。双方达成了一项协议，他们会付钱给墨西哥人，让他们把可卡因从他们手中接走。墨西哥已经有一条通往美国的大型贩运路线。所以哥伦比亚人所要做的就是把它带到墨西哥。墨西哥人可以接手，然后带到美国，并以每公斤、每吨或他们协商的价格交付给他们。所以突然之间，许多原本绕道或飞越墨西哥的可卡因现在正通过墨西哥，然后穿过南部边境进入美国，这意味着大量的新资金涌入了墨西哥贩毒集团。
Border agents in Arizona, like Terry Kirkpatrick, could see the effects of this on the ground. When it hit, it was just like every car in Santa Marijuana had coconut, just like a thousand pounds at a time, four thousand pounds. We got overrun so fast. And as the U.S. continued to crack down on cartels in Colombia, it eventually opened up
像特里·柯克帕特里克这样的亚利桑那州边境特工，可以在实地看到这种情况的影响。当它发生时，就像圣玛丽亚的每一辆车里都有可卡因，一次就是一千磅，四千磅。我们被淹没了，速度太快了。随着美国继续打击哥伦比亚的贩毒集团，它最终打开了
new opportunities for Mexican cartels to become more than just careers. That eventually come to dominate the entire cocaine supply chain. So the big cartels were taking out in Colombia, first Pablo Escobar, and the Ci Cartel were taken down and the Mexican cartels grew and grew particularly the synologues. I'm telling you, I was only like 12 or 13 years old back then and my classmates and I, we were like, I don't want to be as a superhero, like most kids around the world. I want to be a true trafficker because they do have the money and they can do whatever
墨西哥贩毒集团成为不仅仅是搬运工的新机会。他们最终主导了整个可卡因供应链。所以哥伦比亚的大型贩毒集团被消灭了，首先是巴勃罗·埃斯科巴和卡利集团被摧毁，而墨西哥贩毒集团不断壮大，特别是锡那罗亚集团。我告诉你，我当时只有12或13岁，我和我的同学们，我们不像世界上大多数孩子那样想成为超级英雄。我想成为一名真正的毒贩，因为他们确实有钱，而且他们可以做任何
they want. This is Miguel Angel Vega. He grew up in Culea Constinoloa, which by this time had been the epicenter of Mexico's heroin and marijuana trade for decades. But with the rise of cocaine, Cinelo and drug traffickers were getting even more powerful. And Vega watched that happen as he was growing up. And some of his classmates became immersed in narco culture. El Chapa was seen as a modern day robin hood, helping churn the Cinalo and economy with
他们想做的事。这是米格尔·安赫尔·维加。他在锡那罗亚州的库利亚坎长大，到那时为止，这里几十年来一直是墨西哥海洛因和大麻贸易的中心。但随着可卡因的兴起，锡那罗亚的毒贩变得更加强大。维加在成长过程中目睹了这一切。他的一些同学沉浸在毒枭文化中。矮子古兹曼被视为现代罗宾汉，帮助用
drug money. And some of those glass, glass mates ended up being drug traffickers. And all I can tell you about that is some of them are imprisoned or dead. Much of the blood is spilled here in Kulia Khan, the violent nerve center. Instead of joining the Norkos, Vega became an investigative journalist focused on organized crime. He's chronicled the violence and chaos of the drug war, which has done so much over the years to destabilize the country, corrupted institutions, and turn some of
毒资推动了锡那罗亚的经济。而那些同学中，有些人最终成了毒贩。关于这一点，我只能告诉你，他们中有些人已经入狱或死亡。库利亚坎这个暴力的神经中枢，流淌着许多鲜血。维加没有加入毒枭，而是成为了一名专注于有组织犯罪的调查记者。他记录了毒品战争带来的暴力和混乱，这些年来，毒品战争在很大程度上破坏了国家的稳定，腐蚀了机构，并将一些
its most vulnerable people into asylum seekers. Violence seems like these, bodies stuffed in garbage bags, police executed, and journalists assassinated, are directly connected to the wrath of a Sinaloa cartel. And Vega explains that a lot of this violence and chaos was seeded back in the late 80s. Not only because the cocaine trade was being rerouted through Mexico, but also because the cartels were undergoing an internal reorganization. A whole generation of older narcos was leaving the scene. They were getting arrested, they were dying, and a new generation was coming up. And they were dividing up the old territory, forging new alliances and
最脆弱的人变成了寻求庇护者。像这样的暴力事件，尸体被塞进垃圾袋，警察被处决，记者被暗杀，都与锡那罗亚贩毒集团的愤怒直接相关。维加解释说，这种暴力和混乱的许多种子早在80年代末就种下了。不仅因为可卡因贸易被改道通过墨西哥，还因为贩毒集团正在进行内部重组。整整一代老毒枭正在离开舞台。他们被捕了，他们死了，新一代正在崛起。他们正在瓜分旧领土，建立新的联盟和
rivalries. That generation included El Chapo Guzmán, an enormously creative, brutal, and ambitious narco. He was eager for power. Let's just smold the whole world. Let's just conquer the entire world, and that's like his ultimate goal. And Chapo had some new ideas, like this tunnel in Douglas, which according to some estimates allowed the Cinaloa cartel to triple the amount of cocaine they were moving across the border.
竞争。那一代人包括矮子古兹曼，一个极其有创造力、残忍且雄心勃勃的毒枭。他渴望权力。让我们征服整个世界吧，让我们征服整个世界，这就是他的终极目标。矮子有一些新想法，比如道格拉斯的这条隧道，据估计，这条隧道让锡那罗亚贩毒集团通过边境运输的可卡因数量增加了两倍。
So do you think what role did this tunnel play in Chapo kind of becoming Chapo? I think it was a big role. Here's Kiyoki Skinner again, the journalist and juice shop owner from Awa Prieta. I think it really launched a manduous career. The Colombians couldn't believe how fast he got the cocaine to Los Angeles, and they kind of jokingly nicknamed him Speedy. In addition to helping El Chapo make his name, the tunnel created a new kind of notoriety for Douglas Arizona, which had formerly been
那么你认为这条隧道在矮子成为矮子的过程中扮演了什么角色？我认为它扮演了重要角色。这是基奥基·斯金纳，来自阿瓜普里耶塔的记者和果汁店老板。我认为它确实开启了他那庞大的职业生涯。哥伦比亚人无法相信他把可卡因运到洛杉矶的速度有多快，他们开玩笑地给他起了个绰号叫“快手”。除了帮助矮子成名之外，这条隧道还为亚利桑那州的道格拉斯带来了一种新的恶名，这里以前是
a sleepy border town. Suddenly, it was synonymous with the biggest drug trafficking story of the early 90s. And there were a lot of questions about how a smuggling operation of that magnitude could have happened without at least a few local collaborators. Oh, well, which is dated one June 10th. Would you read just the first couple graphs of that? Sure. The specter of a man who called himself Francisco Rafael Camarena still stalks the homes of
一个沉睡的边境小镇。突然之间，它成了90年代初最大毒品贩运故事的代名词。关于如此大规模的走私行动如何在没有至少几个当地合作者的情况下发生，有很多疑问。哦，好吧，日期是6月10日。你能读一下前几段吗？当然。一个自称弗朗西斯科·拉斐尔·卡马雷纳的人的幽灵，仍然徘徊在
the wealthy and the influential here who entertained him in lavish style. In the aftermath of the tunnel's discovery, Kiyoki got to work. He wrote a series of articles for his old newspaper, the Arizona Republic. Chronically, Raphael Comet and his connections to various prominent people, not just in Mexico, but in Douglas. He was always out of the country club and making the right connections, getting to know the right people here before he got this tunnel underway. got this tunnel underway. I mean, it seems like there were a lot of implications in these articles about local officials profiting
这里那些以奢华方式招待他的富有和有影响力的人的家中。在隧道被发现后，基奥基开始工作。他为他的老报纸《亚利桑那共和报》写了一系列文章。记录了拉斐尔·卡马雷纳及其与各种显赫人物的关系，不仅是在墨西哥，而且在道格拉斯。他在隧道动工之前，总是出入乡村俱乐部，建立正确的人脉，结识这里的重要人物。我的意思是，这些文章中似乎有很多暗示，指当地官员从
from this whole scheme. But did anybody in local government ever do any time for this or anything like that? No. No, nobody on the Douglas side. There were also allegations about how agents from the Custom Service may have colluded in the Tunnel scheme. And while again, no one was ever charged, there was a lot of corruption going on within the agency around this time. Here's Terry Kirkpatrick again.
整个计划中获利。但是当地政府有人因此坐牢或类似的事情吗？没有。没有，道格拉斯那边没有人。还有关于海关署的特工可能在隧道计划中勾结的指控。虽然同样，没有人被起诉，但当时该机构内部确实存在大量腐败。这是特里·柯克帕特里克。
At that time, a corruption was so rampant that the U.S. government started a blue ribbon campaign trying to stamp it out and we were so busy trying to work the corruption in trying to weed out our own with these inspectors because they were passing a thousand pounds in the trunk of a car right through the port of entry. It was just a lawless kind of area back in 1989. A senior agent in the Custom Service told me that the tunnel was probably an operation for at least six months. And he said that, quote, everyone would have had to know about the passageway for it to be in regular use for that length of time. After the discovery of the tunnel, El Chapo Guzman came up with new ways of getting drugs across the border, packed in cans of jalapeno peppers or inside coils of insulated wire. Both Francisco Camarena and Felipe Codona Veda fled to Mexico, and it took a long time
当时，腐败非常猖獗，美国政府发起了一场蓝带运动试图根除它，我们忙于处理腐败问题，试图通过这些检查员清除我们自己的人，因为他们让一千磅重的毒品装在汽车后备箱里直接通过入境口岸。1989年那是一个无法无天的地区。海关署的一位高级特工告诉我，这条隧道可能至少运作了六个月。他说，引用他的话，“每个人都必须知道这条通道，它才能在那段时间里被定期使用。”在发现隧道后，矮子古兹曼想出了新的方法将毒品运过边境，装在墨西哥辣椒罐里或绝缘电线圈里。弗朗西斯科·卡马雷纳和费利佩·科多纳·维达都逃到了墨西哥，花了很长时间
to get them back to the United States. Camarena was eventually extradited in 2001, and a couple years later, he pled guilty for his role in the Douglas smuggling conspiracy. He received a sentence of 10 years in federal prison. Coronavirus was extradited in 2003 and tried in 2006. It was released from federal prison in September 2018. But that wasn't the end of the tunnels. The Douglas tunnel was like a prototype.
才把他们带回美国。卡马雷纳最终在2001年被引渡，几年后，他承认了自己在道格拉斯走私阴谋中的角色。他被判处10年联邦监狱监禁。科多纳·维达在2003年被引渡，并于2006年受审。他于2018年9月从联邦监狱获释。但这并不是隧道的终点。道格拉斯隧道就像一个原型。
Even though it was eventually discovered, it was so efficient and effective during the time it was in operation that it paid for itself many times over. It was a successful experiment that proved the viability of underground smuggling. And so... The tunnels after this one, they almost became a nightmare. And it was one tunnel after another tunnel after another tunnel... Tunnel from San Diego to Tijuana. They found a so sophisticated being called a super tunnel.
尽管它最终被发现，但在运作期间它非常高效和有效，以至于它多次收回了成本。这是一个成功的实验，证明了地下走私的可行性。所以……这之后的隧道，几乎成了一场噩梦。一个接一个的隧道……从圣地亚哥到蒂华纳的隧道。他们发现了一个非常复杂的隧道，被称为超级隧道。
The tunnel is over a quarter of a mile long and nearly 70 feet underground, part of it through solid limestone. There's even a phone system. The phones still work. We already say without specific information about where the tunnels are located or just plain luck, they're virtually impossible to find. Ron Clayborn, ABC News on the US, Mexico, board. Most tunnels show up along the Arizona and California borders, in places where the ground
这条隧道全长超过四分之一英里，地下近70英尺，部分穿过坚硬的石灰岩。甚至还有一个电话系统。电话仍然可以使用。我们已经说过，如果没有关于隧道位置的具体信息或纯粹的运气，它们几乎是不可能找到的。罗恩·克莱伯恩，美国广播公司新闻，关于美墨边境。大多数隧道出现在亚利桑那州和加利福尼亚州的边境沿线，在那些地面
is soft enough for digging, but not so soft it will cave in. Some of the tunnels are pretty rudimentary, but some, like the Douglas tunnel, are highly engineered and sophisticated projects with elevators and rail cars. A tunnel discovered in Baja Mexico last year included solar panels to power its ventilation and lighting systems. Most illegal drugs actually come into the country through legal ports of entry. That fact and tunnels are two reasons why Trump's proposed border wall probably wouldn't do much to
足够柔软可以挖掘，但又不会塌陷的地方。有些隧道非常简陋，但有些，像道格拉斯隧道，是高度工程化和复杂的项目，带有电梯和轨道车。去年在墨西哥下加利福尼亚州发现的一条隧道包括用于为其通风和照明系统供电的太阳能电池板。大多数非法毒品实际上是通过合法的入境口岸进入该国的。这一事实和隧道是特朗普提议的边境墙可能不会对
stop drug trafficking. But the US government still sees tunnels as enough of a problem that they've started tunnel task force groups along the border. The groups exist solely to monitor, investigate and prevent tunneling. But tunnels are notoriously difficult to detect, and they keep showing up. When I was in Douglas, I tried to get into the old tunnel, which has been kept open for occasional training sessions by the Border Patrol. Kiyoki Skinner worked his connections and got us into the warehouse where the entrance is, but the tunnel is dank and unmaintained and I was seven months pregnant at the time of the visit. A city worker took one look at me, probably imagined me trying to clamber down the rusty ladder in
阻止毒品贩运起到太大作用的两个原因。但美国政府仍然认为隧道是一个足够大的问题，以至于他们在边境沿线成立了隧道特别工作组。这些小组的存在仅仅是为了监测、调查和防止挖掘隧道。但隧道以难以探测而闻名，而且它们不断出现。当我在道格拉斯时，我试图进入旧隧道，该隧道一直被边境巡逻队保留用于偶尔的训练。基奥基·斯金纳利用他的人脉让我们进入了仓库，那里是入口，但隧道潮湿且缺乏维护，而且我当时怀孕七个月。一名市政工作人员看了我一眼，可能想象着我试图爬下生锈的梯子进入
the dark and then wouldn't let us in after all. But if we couldn't see the architecture of the drug tunnel, then at least we could see the architecture the drug trade has helped to build across the border. So you see it was a pretty nice neighborhood. Once again, we're driving around in Kiyoki's rattling little VW bug. We're exploring the part of town where Awa Ptieta's business people tend to live.
黑暗中，最终还是没让我们进去。但如果我们看不到毒品隧道的建筑，至少我们可以看到毒品贸易在边境两侧帮助建立的建筑。所以你看，这是一个相当不错的社区。我们再次开着基奥基那辆嘎嘎作响的小众甲壳虫车。我们正在探索阿瓜普里耶塔商人们居住的地区。
It's the neighborhood where Kamadenas Ranch home with the hydraulic pool tables still sits, although that's now been converted into a community center. And Kiyoki points out a house on the corner. It's a nice place, with a raw iron fence. The house is made of brick. This is clean money. This is cattle money. This guy's been a cattle guy rancher for years. Because Kyoki has lived here for decades, he's picked up a lot of information about how people make their money.
这是卡马雷纳的牧场住宅所在的地方，里面还有液压台球桌，尽管现在已经改建成了一个社区中心。基奥基指着拐角处的一所房子。这是一个不错的地方，有铁栅栏。房子是砖砌的。这是干净的钱。这是牛的钱。这家伙当了多年的养牛人。因为基奥基在这里住了几十年，他收集了很多关于人们如何赚钱的信息。
As we go around the corner. Look at this place up on the right. Look at the columns on that place. My goodness. It goes over the limit, isn't it? The house takes up the entire block. It has enormous white greco-room and columns and a chandelier dangles over its soaring entryway. Kiyoki says a local narco lives here. It's one of many extravagant narco mansions in the area.
当我们转过弯时。看右边那个地方。看那个地方的柱子。天哪。这超出了限度，不是吗？这所房子占据了整个街区。它有巨大的白色希腊风格房间和柱子，吊灯悬挂在它高耸的入口上方。基奥基说当地的一个毒枭住在这里。这是该地区众多奢华毒枭豪宅之一。
Kiyoki now leads local tours of these places, bringing tourists and snowbirds from Arizona and other parts of the southwest down to Gawk. I said, I'm going to show you what bad habits in the United States has built for us down here. All this money from drug consumption in the United States, this is how it's been spent down here in these houses. And not just these houses. When you stop to think about everything that's funded, directly or indirectly, by American drug consumption,
基奥基现在带领当地的这些地方参观，带游客和来自亚利桑那州及西南部其他地区的候鸟族下来参观。我说，我要向你们展示美国的坏习惯为我们在这里建造了什么。所有这些来自美国毒品消费的钱，这就是它在这里这些房子上的花费方式。不仅仅是这些房子。当你停下来思考所有直接或间接由美国毒品消费资助的东西时，
can make your mind spin. The money finds its way to the people who drive, track, or fly the drugs across Mexico. To the hitmen who battle over cartel territory. To the architects and engineers who build the tunnels for smuggling and the mansions for the kingpins. And to the bribes that pay off cops, politicians, and border patrol agents, so that they'll turn their heads
会让你头晕目眩。钱流向了那些驾驶、运输或空运毒品穿过墨西哥的人。流向了为争夺贩毒集团领土而战的杀手。流向了为走私建造隧道和为毒枭建造豪宅的建筑师和工程师。并流向了贿赂警察、政客和边境巡逻特工的钱，这样他们就会转过头去
and look the other way as this vast and complex system grinds along. And of course, the money also trickles down into the rest of the economy, to the grocery stores and the clothing shops and the gas stations, even to the local juice shop that sells the narcos. They're AR-15 smoothies. 99% Invisible was produced this week by our senior editor Delaney Hall, who finished this story just under the wire. I think that's it.
对这个庞大而复杂的系统视而不见。当然，钱也会流向经济的其他部分，流向杂货店、服装店和加油站，甚至流向卖给毒枭的当地果汁店。他们的AR-15冰沙。99% Invisible本周由我们的高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔制作，她在最后期限前完成了这个故事。我想就是这样。
I also think I was like literally in labor when I tracked the stuff, so if there's anything that doesn't work very well, let me know. And I'll do it again. Okay, bye. You went above and beyond, congratulations. Enjoy your much harder job for the next six months. Mix and Tech Production by Sheree Fusef,
我也觉得我在录音时真的在分娩，所以如果有什么效果不太好，请告诉我。我会再做一次。好的，再见。你做得非常出色，恭喜。享受你未来六个月更艰苦的工作吧。混音和技术制作由Sheree Fusef负责，
Music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Cole-Statty is the digital director. The Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colestad, is the digital director. The rest of the team is Avery Troubleman, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald Vivian Lee, Taren Mazza, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Kiyoki Skinner, Andy Becker,
音乐由Sean Riel创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔蒂是数字总监。团队的其他成员是Avery Troubleman、Joe Rosenberg、Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivian Lee、Taren Mazza、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。本周特别感谢基奥基·斯金纳、安迪·贝克尔，
and the clerks at the US District Court in Tucson, Arizona. To find out more about Kiyoki tours of Aguaprieta, Google his name. That's KEOKI Skinner. We are a project of 91.7 KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, in the world. You can find the show in Joined Discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org.
以及亚利桑那州图森市美国地方法院的书记员。要了解更多关于基奥基的阿瓜普里耶塔之旅，请谷歌他的名字。那是KEOKI Skinner。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心制作。99% Invisible是PRX Radio Topia的成员。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI org。
We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our borders are wide open 24-7. At 99PI, we're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our borders are wide open 24-7 at 99PI.org.
我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我们的边境是24/7全天候开放的。在99PI，我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit org。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我们的边境在99PI.org是24/7全天候开放的。
Radio tapio. From PRX. Radio Tapia. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radio Tapio。来自PRX。Radio Tapia。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。